that's pretty good on campus that's
coming together your neck great
[Music]
mother Tata
just going to sever the news of that
face that's awesome no it looks twice as
creepy yeah looks way creepier
yeah it looks weird it adds like it
looks like it oh yeah do you realize Jim
is just a few days away from being so
young okay this is where white wrote
under it this is gonna be the UH this is
just curry the curry curry one yeah
Stephen Curry this one was easier to
find having never seen the curry series
what yes what is this it's just acting
he literally just does that in reaction
to a joke and we have no idea why he's
doing that motion it's just I guess he's
slapping his knee yeah oh okay I thought
maybe he had delusions of grandeur and
he was masturbating it's like in that
word
we do it's like were they your your fear
your phobia not really I grew up
watching bozo definitely creepy yeah but
yeah
all right so welcome what were your
fears my fears type of a person animal
space alien or whoever bragger fears I
guess yeah alien greys had always been
like you know if your mind like oh I'm
dead and I'm gonna be taken away into
deep space never to be seen again and
just flying stinging insects yeah those
are my top two like fears I guess I mean
ghosts and whatnot are pretty creepy
place so the zippers in the front that
say well how do you do that well these
are attached to velcro so what I like is
when you zip it up Wow mega bug yeah
well we're gonna we can do it we're
gonna put the covers on him yeah
the Cape right Cape that's you know a
barbershop
go yeah okay think I should I put these
that way it's do so okay yeah let's do
let's go yeah have a seat
do you want me keep it open
ah yeah
let's I feel like the lipstick will
cover it up - yeah
that's Doug's face when he sees
Christmas
alright cuz we're doing Halloween open
wide
his movie okay you get a little bit in
the center there yeah good curry face
well I mean yeah heels up in the role of
Joker in the animated series but he got
six and Mark Hamill took it and Mark
Hamill's wore the best Joker's if not
the best Joker but ya know really wonder
what Tim Curry would have been like he's
like I feel like you would have been
good out of it would've been as good but
I think that worked
yeah I feel man I feel like they even
drew him to look like Tim Curry yeah it
feels I really want to see that now yeah
I suppose I've never used them for
anything else though and that she was
yeah something like later cuz he did a
lot of voice work
he was the best Captain Hook in my
opinion oh yeah there's a show called
Peter Pan the Pirates would say only not
a lot of people know about it's very
very good very much like the book and
and he was Captain Hook and he was just
amazing I mean he was funny he was
threatening he was charismatic he you
know had his standards like these really
high standards but he always finds ways
to break him and you know all the
Pirates of personalities and the laws
boys and stuff like it's a really really
good show extra
it's stream' where we will be used on
that oh I can't talk with them clearly
always just file your teeth pretty good
yeah oh man well you can definitely see
it the angry well you know I was gonna
say maybe they change okay we're trying
to get the eyebrows right now on this
one they're really really down but then
that other ones in tight
yeah the book is this one he's being
like really aggressive at man yes so
they changes eyebrows I'm wondering that
yeah maybe that's like a detail I never
noted like something was actually subtle
in it as far as scary clowns go I did
like Sarsgaard oh you know I thought
yeah but spazzy run though he does
asleep so you did a line of coke and
just went and you can happen so he wrote
me a little bag
[Music]
good I'll be ahead go ahead and feel I
feel a little bit more like you show
your teeth my fiancee said that this
would happen so he wrote me look back at
speech
[Applause]
and you can scream I mean you can stream
my fiance said that this would happen
so he
[Applause]
[Music]
to be sure I said you can straight you
know how do you have your body you
didn't really go yeah everybody
projected and wrote me a little speech
yeah yeah good boy on the set and thank
you my fiance said that this would
happen so here I say on this one rather
than rather than doing to do you boys go
ahead just still have it be hybrid you
know my fiance said that this would
happen so he wrote me a little backup
speech
[Music]
[Applause]
great gun powered by Hyper's breath
never run out of ammunition so it looks
like you accept the gun down but you're
actually having it and just one last
yeah I know that's good hey and I'm this
one go ahead walk same way just a hint
slower ready action
perfect we'll do one more just a heck of
a do one where it's like you're walking
then like you the walk was too pretty
[Laughter]
perfect ready and action
one more seeping you doing like really
Bailey yeah if I keep walking me with a
limp just this week hey ready
[Music]
damn Walmart oh no she's really really
hurt actually
yeah action
Kiki nicely done hot like steak or
course you can took a knife for this
album yep it's just the Chola so hot it
burned you know so I can break that one
to actual guys yeah yeah duct tape and
white duct tape for some reason like a
teacher for a second no I'm just like oh
like I always sucked right back to third
grade I'm like all right so what is
we're gonna start as beautiful belly
we're gonna back out here and I'm gonna
say line and Tamara guess a question and
then and I'm gonna say turn and you all
turn to look at the camera like waiting
for an answer like yeah my scooby-doo
book
okay hey steady was it you want me to
grab don't want it why question why
didn't you take him to a hospital
turn
great Walter go ahead like more behind
dammit there you go yeah hey Walter goes
a little bit of an angle be a little bit
hunched over there you go okay can you
do that gauges yeah one D it works yeah
well we're we're seasonaire I can cry
because another heads go beyond third
oh yeah pink belly okay
you beat me out I'm sorry maybe my
stomach's just so gorgeous than yours oh
I just think okay so this is going to be
but you're gonna be severed okay it so
leave like I got some room and yeah I
think yeah exactly
those are the exact closes I was gonna
have a very gala days yeah
let's see good nod
Trevor eyes a little bigger okay and
Malcolm go ahead and have one we just
look kind of like yeah those are good so
what is this the Twinkie shot
yeah he's obsessed with it the
miniseries he obsessed with food no food
is from the monster squad review yeah
cuz he's a fat kid he just goes yes I
say use your the fake it it's what's
wrong and this one is Oh sister yeah
yeah I think you're just yeah is it
possible to hold it up while still like
okay yeah so you can all the real give
they go flying grape yeah food as they
find this one he's obsessed with you
just go Tom I just drop this
that's just I keep the box with me go Oh
missus you can hand the box off no like
it's they're both for you funny I mean
can you play with that once I'm out oh
so like there's a guitar oh yeah yes
okay quite understand mouthful
yeah and action
whoa in this one he's obsessed with
sound like the Frankenstein box
okay definitely not as good as I
remember no they're really not I used to
love these dandies yeah all right ready
and action but in this one he's obsessed
with so many of those serials do not
hold up
Marian Frankenberry still do though yeah
I love what she's down there I thought I
knew you
[Applause]
he looks over here but there are these
over there in response support what
yes he water you went to a hospital I
thought I knew you
you're all going to a hospital soon I
still like to take we're going to be
like right here at the light in slower
just in kids that runs together damn it
Mike we kind of need you to kind of
justify your kinda mark oh okay for
being here
wonderful now I can explain my
incredibly important backstory and oh
we're kind of passed it to our mark we
could probably get you a bonus feature
on the blu-ray oh it's there
you know hey how you holding up by blood
it looks so yeah it does
good job beard Halloween store
yeah yes I know me
eight guys standing around we're all
just like looking at this happen are you
getting everyone watch everyone's
watching what I tell the time how much
you get it I mean that's pretty yeah I
get something a little wet the clock
cover yeah let's go see if we can smear
does little like under the eyes yeah
like I know just oh yeah yeah do you
wash it out
you sure do or other eyelid there to be
safe yeah close your I am yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you put a bunch of
underneath why no I was gonna say just
like what we did with what she did with
the wiping there just go ahead sir it's
me the blood a little closer to be I
just with the paper towel I don't think
we need to put my gels yeah
was it it's a feral cat bounce yeah okay
I mean it's supposed to just splash in
her face so it's now like no God no I
don't look like just what splash splat
[Laughter]
just a little bit more like both sides
of the well I mean I say put more on the
face person than what your father face
I'm covering up the little white area
that shows from the shirt yeah yeah
that'll break up that line that was good
yep
BAM oh okay so like half the makeup is
staying on fire the other half is coming
off but what we realize it kinda makes
like a cool Batman villain or Slipknot
remember we don't know but you can do a
lot of is a character here there is
somebody make this cuz this is kind of
this is creepy yeah yeah one clown guy
yeah whatever that guy is so yeah Rob
Zombie make make some out of this go
that's your homework homework
we gotta guard these scars yes
so you want to replace an English clown
trying to do a New England accent so you
go to Sweden and bring in a guy named I
heard on my there because I mean I
unless him to stand in here at um but to
say his family he just have a
straight-up American yeah no I mean you
hear the name like his brothers and
stuff and they're very you know Sven or
whatever they are you know just very
very Swedish names yeah yeah that's
pretty common though like across the
world to find like the standard
Midwestern dialect because our media is
so widespread well let's think about it
like some of our most American
superheroes Wolverines Australian Batman
was Welsh Wonder Woman is Israeli and
Superman's British yeah isn't he British
I think so yeah so like there's a very
few of them are like you know they all
do great jobs right now bales failed is
his he tried his best Christian Bale oh
no but you can tell I mean there was
never like it oh he's phoning you know
he's like no no he's clearly putting his
all into it he had to play a lot of
tricky stuff but yes and it's a real
alive it's just the voice I play more
the director for the house like director
sure said you know okay you know well um
let's take a day to work on this voice
cuz we're going to do a lot this is
Batman we're going to do a lot with this
oh oh you touched Oh No yeah you know I
was saying with the Tim Curry one wait
is it yeah a little but this one's
inside out but this one I used the
scratch oh sure we go do we have other
way no husband's got as well / - okay
yeah then the inside out it's pretty
unless well the old the other thing we
could do we just wear them both inside
out
like that's part of the character okay I
mean there there is a part where that's
a close-up on the hands but at the same
time I mean okay could argue it's just
kind of part of the character yeah
yeah there's more murderous clam much
you only see the inside I mean he is
less subtle
no it happened yeah well like I say it
just doesn't feel like there's anything
down there right yeah and curry cloud
it's like you definitely know those
always there as you thought that's twice
I up the noses isn't it because I
did them the Tim Curry one too okay
yes even play like this yeah it does not
good we're weird on the other hand and
you know just like constantly have it's
showing where it's just like yeah well
but even yeah I mean you can still see
yeah like the exact wrong color red
that's like the exact color you do not
want on why it's right
[Laughter]
you